[Music]
thank you throughout the course of
history Humanity has been marked by
epidemics that wreak havoc on
individuals communities and entire
societies
I'm rich Burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives five
experts delve into some of the deadliest
diseases that have shaped our world and
they consider their far-reaching
consequences we begin in the 1980s as we
examine the biology and symptoms of one
of the most notorious diseases of our
time
thank you
[Music]
in the early 1980s a new disease began
appearing in the United States with an
unusual combination of symptoms
swollen lymph nodes pneumonia and a rare
form of skin cancer
many of the patients who showed these
symptoms soon died
by the summer of 1982 the new disease
had been given a name acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome or Aids
story of AIDS and the virus that causes
it HIV is a great example of how
evolutionary biology offers insights in
the fields of medicine and Public Health
the HIV virus is the so-called
retrovirus that attacks the human immune
system primarily a type of cell called
helper T cells that play a central role
in the body's defense against infectious
diseases
the virus enters these cells and then
makes a copy of its genome that gets
incorporated into the Genome of the
helper T cell
this is a very effective way for a virus
to hide because the host can't tell the
difference between its own parts of the
genome versus the parts that came from
the virus
meanwhile the virus can make copies of
itself using the host cell's machinery
because the virus is hidden within the
host genome the only way for the immune
system to get rid of this kind of virus
is to destroy any cells that have been
infected
but by destroying immune cells the host
becomes more susceptible to infections
from other pathogens
the Hallmark of AIDS
the particular variety of HIV or human
immunodeficiency virus responsible for
the AIDS epidemic is a strain called
hiv-1
closely related virus called SIV short
for Simeon immunodeficiency virus
affects non-human primates
comparisons of the genomes of SIV with
different strains of hiv-1 allowed
researchers to create a phylogenetic
tree depicting The evolutionary history
of SIV and hiv-1 this analysis showed
that hiv-1 evolved from a strain of SIV
that infects chimpanzees
so some of the SIV virus switched from
infecting chimps to infecting humans
when did that happen
researchers used a molecular clock to
estimate how long it took for the
differences in the RNA Genome of
different HIV strains to evolve those
studies suggest that the common ancestor
of all HIV strains appeared in the early
20th century
what's interesting is using an
evolutionary approach to reconstruct the
history of HIV shows us that the virus
was infecting humans for more than half
a century before the outbreak became
more widespread in the 1980s
another important conclusion from this
analysis is that hiv-1 has become very
diverse in just a short amount of time
since it began infecting humans HIV has
evolved into four distinct groups
labeled m n o and P each with a slightly
different envelope or outer membrane
the M group is responsible for the
majority of HIV infections worldwide
moreover a variety of subtypes have
evolved within each group that differ in
their genome sequence
we now know that HIV evolves rapidly in
part because it has the extremely high
mutation rate typical for an RNA virus
as one 2015 study put it RNA viruses
exist as extremely diverse populations
with every possible spontaneous mutation
along the genome appearing within each
patient every day
hiv-1 lacks the ability to proofread for
transcription errors which may occur as
often as one out of every thousand base
pairs for every round of copying
and hiv-1 does reproduce quickly
the combined result of Rapid copying
with a rapid rate of uncorrected
mutations is that HIV is evolving even
as it replicates within the same host
the virus that is in the host at death
from AIDS is not the same virus that
caused the initial infection
The evolutionary approach to
understanding HIV also revealed the
history of a second less deadly strain
of HIV
hiv-2 affects a much smaller number of
people primarily in Africa
hiv-2 is closely related to a strain of
SIV that infects a different primate a
monkey called the mangabi
study mangobes are commonly kept as pets
in some parts of West Africa this
probably made it easier for the virus to
switch hosts and begin infecting humans
influenza is caused by RNA viruses that
mostly infect birds and mammals because
the RNA of the virus must enter into a
host cell in order to reproduce they
have become very specialized on
individual host species many influenza
strains have evolved to be very
effective at entering the host cells of
birds
yet occasionally a mutation occurs that
makes the influenza virus more capable
of infecting human cells
this jump to humans tends to occur with
some regularity leading to the seasonal
flu outbreaks that occur each year
the annual flu vaccine is made based on
predictions about which mutations are
most likely to occur and typically
includes at least three different
strains as a hedge against uncertainty
on rare occasions mutations occur in a
deadly strain of influenza infecting
another species that make it capable of
infecting humans
in 2009 a strain known as H1N1 evolved
from a virulent strain of influenza that
was infecting pigs
although H1N1 went on to displace
H3N2 is the most common strain in humans
for some years both are included in flu
vaccines luckily this particular swine
flu turned out to be relatively mild in
humans
but in 1918 an especially virulent
strain of influenza led to a deadly
worldwide outbreak
some patients died within a day of
developing symptoms
yet the strain was able to spread
largely because of World War One
in fact the conditions were perfect for
spreading disease soldiers were
traveling around the world living in
close quarters
those that developed the flu were
brought to crowded makeshift hospitals
these conditions favored the rapid
evolution of a highly virulent strain of
influenza that killed 10 to 20 percent
of people that became infected totaling
as many as 100 million people worldwide
DNA since retrieved from victims who
perished between the spring of 1918 and
the winter of 1919 from a geography
spanning Alaska to England show little
variation and are all equally virulent
the name Spanish flu then is a
xenophobic misnomer it reflects the fact
that the combatant nations of the Great
War which did not end until November of
1918 actively censored news reports of
its spread only in neutral Spain was the
reportage allowed which gave rise to the
erroneous narrative that it had emerged
there
historically there have been documented
influenza pandemics dating back to the
late 9th century of our era all of them
zoonotic diseases just like the black
death that is they're caused by the
transfer of germs from animals in Greek
so on to humans
in both cases as we now know the rapid
spread of zoonotic diseases
is traceable to multiple multiple
vectors including the globally mobile
population of wild waterfowl and
Shorebirds which could of course travel
widely and rapidly even in ages when
humans could not
surprisingly scientific data shows a
marked surge in the truly Global scope
of influenza just when we would expect
it in 1510 when European colonization of
the Americas was devastating indigenous
peoples with no immunity to foreign
diseases we then observe a steady
increase from there until further marked
upticks in the mid 19th century when
steamship travel fueled growing global
trade and tourism Industries resulting
in the pandemic of 1889.
indeed Moorings and talbenberger found
that in 1918-19 mortality
disproportionately affected adults in
the prime of life with those aged 20 to
40 dying three times more often than
their older and younger contemporaries
hence the number of tragically orphaned
children within this group the highest
mortality rate occurred around the age
of 29. that is among those who had been
born during or just after the pandemic
of 1889 and who had not benefited from
any of its immunological effects
now let's move into the 18th century a
time when cures for and prevention of
diseases were desperately needed
let's take a look back in time to a
historically important disease the virus
known as smallpox whose death rate
rivaled the plague
one of modern medicines true triumphs
has been smallpox eradication
now the cause of smallpox is variola
virus which is thought to have evolved
from animals in the Central African
rainforests thousands of years ago
the virus became established in humans
in the Nile River Valley approximately
10 000 years ago
evidence of smallpox was even found in
mummified bodies of the Egyptian
pharaohs that dates back 10 000 BC
later the disease became widespread in
Europe and Asia killing nearly half a
million Europeans yearly at the turn of
the 19th century with over 80 percent of
them being children
now smallpox enters the body through
infectious particles contacting the
mucous membranes or via the respiratory
system via inhalation or droplets
from its initial site of invasion it
spreads locally to lymph nodes then
jumps into the bloodstream where it can
invade other major organs
the pox on the skin are the visual clue
of the internal disease
now later colonization of the quote New
World carried smallpox to the Americas
ironically it played a major role in the
conquest of Mexico and Peru as well as
the European settlement of North America
many of the indigenous Native American
populations whose immune systems had
never been exposed to the virus couldn't
fight off the disease and they died
as late as the 20th century there were
millions of worldwide deaths from
smallpox
the who or World Health Organization
estimated that as recently as 1967 15
million people contracted smallpox and 2
million died of it that year
in order to reduce the risk of smallpox
and ingenious preventive inoculation
called variation was devised as early as
the 10th Century in Asia
individuals were deliberately injected
with smallpox by blowing dried smallpox
scabs into the nose of the individual
these individuals usually contracted a
mild form of smallpox leaving them
immune only one to two percent of these
patients died
compared to 30 percent mortality for
others dying from smallpox without the
virulation prevention
in 1700 this procedure was being widely
used in India Africa and the Ottoman
Empire but smallpox was still a serious
threat with no treatment
therefore developing a more scientific
vaccination for prevention was a World
Health Care priority
a more traditional type of smallpox
immunization was developed in 1796 by
English physician Edward Jenner
even though he was unaware that smallpox
was caused by a virus he discovered that
immunity to smallpox could be conveyed
by inoculating a person with material
from a cowpox lesion a pox virus from
the same family
he called the material quote vaccine
from the root word quote vodka which is
Latin for cow and hence the origin of
the term vaccination
now the vaccine is no longer a cowpox
derivative like Jenner's instead it's a
live vaccine derived from a similar pox
virus the vaccinia virus
the last case of smallpox in the U.S was
in 1949
but in 1967 the disease was still
endemic in 31 countries
since the quote incubation period for
smallpox is relatively long
7 to 17 days and quarantine can be
effective in halting transmission
smallpox was a prime candidate for
worldwide eradication
the who worked hard over the next 10
years to eradicate the disease and the
last naturally occurring smallpox case
in the world was in Somalia in 1977.
in 1980 the world was declared free of
smallpox
now these eradication programs
demonstrate how International
collaboration and cooperation can have a
significant worldly benefit
except for laboratory stockpiles
smallpox has been eliminated
however there is heightened concern
since 9 11 that the virus might be used
as an agent of bioterrorism and
contingency plans are in place by
governments around the world
I want to discuss the relationship
between global cooling and the spread of
the new disease
in the Middle Ages people blamed
disasters on an Angry God doubling down
on destruction
beginning in the 20th century we have
become increasingly aware that human
incursion into forests and habitat
destruction have led to animal diseases
jumping the species barrier and
infecting humans this was true of HIV
from primates in the 1980s Ebola from
bats in 2014 and the devastating
covid-19 pandemic from bats that changed
our lives beginning in 2020.
the climate change that took place in
the 14th century also put pressure on
animals who had to move to seek food
Bubonic plague is caused by a bacterium
yersinia pestis which is a disease of
rodents
Manchurian marmots also called tarbagan
marmots from Central Asia
and black rats radisratus originally
from Southeast Asia but ubiquitous in
Europe served as the major vectors of
the disease
fleas from these animals serve to spread
the Y pestis to humans
while other rodents also carry plagues
black rats move around as effectively as
humans
they joined the Caravans along the Silk
Road taking advantage of available food
more importantly these rats are also
called ship rats for their ability to
Hitch ride on ships
they lived in the holds where they could
eat at their leisure and climbed down
the ropes when ship stopped to inhabit
New Towns
bringing their diseases and fleas with
them
prolific shipping along the Indian Ocean
brought the rats everywhere
marmots didn't move around as much but
they carry a particularly deadly form of
plague mnemonic plague that is spread by
aerosol transmission through the air
bypassing the need for fleas
Scholars have struggled to understand
how this plague spread rapidly with such
deadly results
DNA studies of plague cemeteries
confirmed the presence of why pestis
even if other diseases spread through a
weakened population at the same time
what became called the Black Death that
killed so many was indeed bubonic plague
what was this disease like
medieval descriptions of the disease
were Vivid
boccaccio a 14th century Observer
described hard dark lumps called bubos
that developed in lymph nodes on the
body
others described brews-like purplish
splotches that appeared on the body
these dark splotches were called God's
tokens because once the skin darkened
death was almost certain
finally the worst symptoms came from
pneumonic plague that was spread through
the air victims began to cough and spit
up blood contemporary observers wrote
with horror at this virulent form of
Airborne plague
breath spread the infection among those
speaking together victims violently
coughed up blood and after three days of
incessant vomiting they died
and with them died not only everyone who
talked with them but also anyone who had
acquired or touched or laid hands on
their belongings
this coughing plague took between 95 and
100 of their victims
for most people who survived they were
better off after the Black Death than
they were before one group however that
was definitely not better off was the
nobility and or religious institutions
that owned a lot of land
so in other words those at the very top
of society for the first time in
centuries found themselves at a
disadvantage
the rigid three Estates model of
medieval Society those who fight the
Nobles those who pray the clergy and
those who work everyone else began an
accelerated rearrangement and collapse
something that had started already with
the development of trade networks
specialization and trades or occupations
and the rise of a merchant class just
prior to the outbreak of the Black Death
indeed somewhat ironically it was these
very trade networks that would carry
that initial seating of plague
throughout the Medieval World and allow
it to spread so quickly and ferociously
and in turn
plague would accelerate medieval
Europe's transition from a rigid
hierarchical structure based on service
and loyalty to a more market-driven and
proto-capitalist economy
in the aftermath of the Black Death the
Lords had titles and lands but were
largely cash poor and desperate for
Laborers
by contrast a newly and increasingly
wealthy Merchant class had cash and
goods but no titles
this is where we start to see marriages
happen between the nobility and the
wealthier families of the merchant class
which in turn further undermine
traditional social structures and
hierarchies
so what have we got so far in the long
term aftermath of the plague we have
increased productivity and efficiency in
manufacturing and trades
something that seems to be pointing us
straight in the direction of eventually
the Industrial Revolution
we have an increasingly secular society
in which hierarchies might further be
flattened and which may have been part
of the influence for the Protestant
Reformation
we have increased trade and a
market-based protocapitalist economy
which provided greater opportunities and
social Mobility for members of the lower
classes in addition to many other after
effects
we have a labor shortage that similarly
provided greater social Mobility for
those in the lower classes
we have greater resources available to
people which means as a general rule the
population got healthier they ate more
protein they drank more good wine and
beer they had plenty of better
with the surplus of nutrition and other
resources there was more room for
artistic and literary expression
indeed throughout the Medieval World in
the face of so Much Death and
destruction individuals and institutions
stepped up to provide support and care
for those who needed it most
with every outbreak that occurred from
1353 to 1720 local governments expanded
and refined the Social and Health
Services of their communities in order
to better combat plague and provide
relief and support
we have learned a lot of lessons in the
last couple of years and there are sure
to be more to come
and I hope that one of the lessons
learned from both the black death and
covid-19 was and is that we need to have
better safety nets in place
our medical infrastructure desperately
needs an overhaul a system in which
health insurance is directly connected
to employment doesn't make any sense
when the pandemic causes many people to
lose their jobs and thus their insurance
at exactly the moment when they need it
most
when a crisis like this arises and
people are out of work through no fault
or choice of their own the argument for
a steady Universal basic income starts
to make a whole lot more sense compared
to the Mad scramble to figure out who
needs benefits and Welfare the most at
any particular moment
more than anything I think we have
learned how interlinked we all are
especially in this truly globalized
reality and which we now live
and while it may be the case that our
interconnectedness is one of the reasons
covet has spread so far and so fast it
is my hope that this same
interconnectedness is going to be what
helps Humanity ultimately beat this
disease as we share information and
resources and vaccines and Medical
Treatments with one another
and as I always say what is most
important is that we keep learning and
that we do not forget the lessons of the
past
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandrium